as you all know the final debate took
place earlier this week at Lynn
University in Boca Raton Florida and of
course after the debate all the
political operatives in media what they
do is they all comment on the debate
from spin alley so we decided to send
our most trustworthy correspondent to
cover this historic event our old
friends triumph the insult comic are
reporting here live at the presidential
debate in Boca Raton Florida Bob
Schieffer is the moderator he's 75 years
old for as the residents here in Boca
Raton call him middle-aged Florida
audience is being instructed not to
applaud and to refrain from dying during
the day now telling what crowd to turn
off their cell phones because they might
get their fear with Mitt Romney's
circuitry debate takes place in live
University and Here I am with the
president of Lynn University I've never
heard of Lynn University and I
understand either of you the university
is actually a very prestigious
institution it's a great safety school
for kids who don't get into Clown
College
in a few minutes there's to be a
five-minute intermission so that the
audience can unwrap their hard candy one
more joke you come to love it the crowd
is so old that Bob Schieffer is already
collected five phone numbers get to work
there's CNN's cover those lines during
the debate that's not from a focus group
it's actually Bob Scheepers heartbeat
okay he doesn't get david shuster so
much now you're coming see I'm happy to
brighten your day
given the Jurong Current TV seriously
I'm Gordon I saw your ratings really
yeah I used an electron microscope okay
no problem I I leave to the right myself
but only because they cut my left
testicle we're now in the spin room
it's Norm Coleman the former senator
from Minnesota look at this guy go look
at them to defend around this imagine
how good it would be if he believed what
he was saying
only thing whiter than Boca Raton or his
team so tell me this about the Romney
because the biggest criticism I have is
that he's but he's not consistent you
know it absolutely
give me a break Romney changes positions
more than last he did under prom night
over there okay governor Sununu how are
you from the Conan O'Brien show terrify
for me so you're in favor of smaller
government had larger cheeseburgers
governor which would you rather have
your country back or baby backs just in
case Mitt Romney needs advice on what
not to do governor Rubio I know you're a
great man but I hope you know that in
real life if you appeared I'm governor
Romney's property
he would have you shot
legendary Congressman Peter King of New
York He is calling security because he
believes this reporter is a Muslim I
would leave now governor Pataki are
against no intervention right you made
the career out of it which is formal you
don't want the government to get
involved cause people I am very much in
favor of leaving people on their own
government should get out of the way in
terms and in the in in terms of marriage
equality as well I think the state
should make decisions okay so you're
sort of kind of the government should be
involved in that so you're going you
might say you go both ways
trickle-down government I'm sorry I have
I haven't done since I was neutered I
haven't trickled down there 20 years
explain to me how Romney could have
possibly won this debate go ahead who
else complain to me that he did listen
to this guy he cares less about what
comes out of his mouth then Kim
Kardashian cares about what goes into
her trying to get them to shop to ruin
your shop no not possibly but no Brian
show I'm trying to ruin your shot you're
about to ruin a live shot seriously Boca
Raton I haven't seen that much white
hair since Madonna climbed out of a
limousine just trying to ruin the shop
for just a second okay can they ruin the
job just for a second I just want to get
in
yes
[Applause]
I'm on Fox News
little bit quick ruin here we go 1 2 3
I'm free ruin
he loves it look at them comedy is the
universal language these are differences
wiped away by one ruin shot you're right
you're right you're right
one more ruin okay get them Sean Hannity
shot sorry everyone
excuse me just trying to ruin the shot
okay I'm not going to ruin this done
ruining
let's stop Sean Sean no kazoo is in
great shape of course who wouldn't be if
they shoveled crap all day long everyone
is left except for this reporter from
Poland because of the time difference he
thinks the debate starts in 12 hours
your reporter saying good night
[Applause]
you